ah
hoy vamos a empezar con una pregunta y
la pregunta es qué harían si les dijeran
que tienen un mes para vivir
seguramente han escuchado esta pregunta
alguna vez han jugado con la idea de la
noción
piénsenlo piénsenlo tantito considerando
un momentito y ahorita regresamos al
vivir
qué es la vida
entonces vamos a hablar de vivir tenemos
que hablar de la vida verdad no
necesariamente porque los conceptos son
un poquito diferente la vida y siempre
hablamos de nuestros propósitos de vida
lo que queremos lograr en la vida pero
se nos olvida muchas veces el vivir sano
la vida no es una cosa si es una cosa
pero el vivir
pero esperamos en lo mismo de computer
aclaremos entonces algunas cosas primero
empecemos por la vida
la vida como se entiende pues el
concepto más conocido es el círculo de
la vida así todo el mundo lo conoce
y se puede expresar de muchas maneras
este es una donde nacemos crecemos
vivimos envejecemos y nos morimos
una manera de ver el círculo de la vida
otra manera de ver a decir probabilidad
es algo como esto donde en el centro
tenemos un organismo unicelular
de a partir del cual surgió toda la vida
en este planeta hoy día como podemos ver
dominado absolutamente por insectos y
bacterias
y aún así nos creemos los dueños del
planeta no esta es otra manera de ver el
círculo de la vida
esta es otra manera de decir q la vida
mucha gente piensa que es el enfoque
tiene que ser humano somos egoístas
entonces pues yo me voy a enfocar en mi
espiritualidad mi bienestar y nutrición
me juego mi trabajo también valioso es
un círculo de la vida
pero estoy seguro que cuando yo dije la
palabra
la frase círculo de vida todos pensaron
pero bueno no venimos a hablar solamente
la vida venimos a hablar del vivir y les
quiero presentar algo que yo considero
para mí que funcionaba muy bien y lo
considero algo y lo llamo el círculo de
vivir
con la diferencia entre el círculo de
vida pues vivir es hacer realmente algo
no es un concepto sino es acción y
consiste de estos cuatro pasos
el primer paso es crear algo
crear algo construir algo hacer algo
el segundo punto es disfrutarlo sacarle
alegría provecho
tener placer el tercer punto es
compartirlo
y ahora vamos a ver más detalles y el
último punto muy importante es dejarlo
ir
estos son los cuatro pasos
de un círculo de vivir
yo os voy a explicar en un
por ejemplo personal
o como lo descubre y para mí el círculo
de vivir se expresa perfectamente en una
actividad que es construir castillos de
arena
o empiezas vas a una playa una arenera
un lugar donde hay arena y empieza a
construir crear algo llamémosle castillo
porque rara vez parecen un castillo pero
una forma de la arena y nos creando lo
estás construyendo estás dedicándole
energía tiempo y amor para construir
algo mientras lo haces o después que lo
termines lo vas a disfrutar lo estás
disfrutando mucho estás viendo tu
creación estás jugando con ella digo
también me ven con cara raro porque sigo
jugando con mis castillos de arena como
niño y con mis niños pero es disfrutarlo
es sumamente placentero hacer
compartirlo muchas formas alguien puede
pasar por ahí verlo observarlo eso es
compartirlo alguien viene a jugar
contigo al lleven a construir o destruir
el castillo contigo es compartiendo y
eso da muchísima alegría y dejarlo ir
qué mejor manera de ver la vida como un
castillo arena dónde
el día siguiente está seguro que no va a
existir
y eso nos va a llevar
un perro que paso por ahí la marea una
tormenta
un ser humano no cuidados miles de cosas
pero pues te lo puedo garantizar no va a
estar ahí mañana y así es también la
vida entonces estas cosas lo puedes
aplicar absolutamente a todos
vamos a ver un poquito más a detalle el
primer punto
qué es crear
normalmente pensamos oye pues tengo que
pintar algo tengo que hacer una
escultura tengo que construir sea tengo
tiene que ser algo tangible y está bien
también lo es pero una amistad lo crea
un sentimiento lo creas un rencor lo
creas
a todo eso es creación creas cosas
constantemente
lo importante es seguir creando nunca
parar no solo crear una cosa y esperar
si se logre o trabajas toda tu vida para
lograrlo crea constantemente todos los
días todo el tiempo nuevas cosas porque
no caigas en la trampa de tener que
categorizar lo de o esto es lo máximo
esta es una gran cosa que va a impactar
al mundo
pequeños detalles
el segundo paso
es disfrutar
esto es sumamente importante porque
crearíamos algo que construyéramos algo
que nos causa dolor o tristeza
y aún así lo hacemos vamos increíble los
humanos somos capaces de crear y
construir con propósito cosas que nos
van a dañar
de ese cuenta y piénsenlo siempre desde
el punto de vista de quiero disfrutarlo
quiero que me dé alegría quiero que me
dé placer
esto es sumamente importante
a la vida
el tercer punto
es compartirlo
sumamente importante compartir yo puedo
tener una casa muy hermosa y grande y
con muchas cosas pero si estoy allá
dentro sólo lo voy a disfrutar realmente
puede ser hasta cierto punto viendo
cuando puedo compartirlo con otras
personas cuando realmente lo puedo
tener ese espacio con otros seres
humanos o mascotas o cualquier forma de
vida
es mucho más placentero era mucho más
alegría y a ellos también
compartimos con la compartición se
agranda la alegría entonces compartir es
sumamente importante
y muchas veces el compartir también es
totalmente indirecto tú puedes hacer
algo buen gesto
o por ejemplo yo a quien en monterrey
muchas veces pues en el tráfico ya lo
conocemos todo
hago un gesto en mi manera de conducir
y pueda he visto que yo hago un gesto
una manera que dejo alguien pasar o algo
hago un gesto extraordinario
en el tráfico y en unos minutos más o
segundos más veo que alguien lo repite
el carro que pasó y ahora veo que está
haciendo lo mismo y eso es compartir
también
el cuarto punto es dejarlo ir
sumamente importante aprender a dejar ir
las cosas
oye creaste un café o tampa mucho me va
a divertirme dar mucha alegría hasta
dice para gente lo compartí ya que lo
agarro se me cae el piso
tengo varias opciones
mucha gente lamentablemente toma la
decisión de enojarse lamentarlo pasar
todo el resto del día
en muy mal estado mental porque se me
cayó un café déjalo ir puedes hacerte
otra ojalá y si no pues aún así no hay
nada que puede ser respecto déjalo ir
así pero muy fácil mi café se me cayó y
lo dejé oye mi ser querido se murió
alguien cuesta dejarlo ir
sonará muy cruel pero es lo mismo
el café
ambos somos cosas que estamos existimos
aquí por un
sumamente corto momento
en este concepto
ilusionario ha llamado tiempo inventado
por hombres y realmente no hay ninguna
diferencia o sea es lo mismo es dejar ir
todo tenemos que practicar desde lo más
profundo difícil hasta lo más sencillo
que nunca
se pone mejor la vida y bueno como se
dieron cuenta los números estaban
totalmente en orden equivocada y es
porque acabo de crear algo que a mí me
divierte
tal vez pero me divirtió mucho
obviamente lo compartí con todos ustedes
y con un botón
desaparecer y lo dejé
pero lo más importante que traté de
mostrar con esos números es que estos
pasos no son pasos que tienes que tomar
de una forma ordenada
no tienes que crear algo
disfrutarlo compartirlo y dejarlo ir de
ninguna manera puedes empezar con
dejarlo ir puedes empezar con
disfrutarlo puedes empezar con
compartiendo y luego compartiendo y
compartiendo y luego creas algo y luego
no hay ninguna regla las reglas los
haces tú
tú eres el dueño de tu vida y si tienes
dudas de ese tema cuestiona lo tú tienes
que entender que es tu vida y es tu
responsabilidad
y bueno porque vivir tu vida
de esta manera porque verlo como un
círculo de vivir porque aplicar estas
cosas yo los veo que tiene algunos
beneficios
y la más obvia es que lo que tú haces
hoy va a afectar
el mejor momento de plantar un árbol fue
hace 20 años
el segundo mejor momento es ahora mismo
entonces empieza ahora mismo a hacer las
cosas que quieres ver qué sucede en el
futuro
el cambio a veces puede ser rápido a
veces lento pero como acción
otro muy importante beneficio que tiene
esta manera de ver la vida es que te
brinda propósitos personales
plural propósitos personales tuyo es
decir viviendo así creando cosas
constantemente te permite también crear
muchos sueños metas misiones visiones
como quieras pero son cosas que tú
proyectas lograr en la vida quieres
lograr
entonces si tienes un solo sueño en la
vida si no se cumple cómo te vas a
sentir muy mal
desilusionado decepcionado con tu vida
porque no tener un millón de sueños que
vamos cumpliendo varios todos los días y
eso les aseguro que les brinda un
sentimiento de propósito
estoy logrando algo y ojos son tuyos son
personales puedes si quieres
explicárselo a alguien pero asegúrate
que no dejes nadie más juzgarte o
decidir por ti si realmente estás
logrando tus sueños no puede ser ir
hasta taquería aquí a la vuelta ver a tu
amigo con has visto en dos años esos se
vale esos son sueños también y yo
personalmente tengo millones de esos los
voy cumpliendo al día primera un
propósito
y el beneficio más importante es la
felicidad personal
si no piensa en los cuatro pasos crear
algo
y disfrutarlo
compartirlo y dejarlo ir
para mí cualquiera de esos cuatro en sí
solo y hecho por mis razones y mi forma
me da felicidad
y crear construir me encanta me apasiona
me llena me pone en un estado de flow y
realmente lo disfruto
híjole
lo comparto que más felicidad cuando
puedo jugar con mis cosas con alguien
más compartir mi vida dar amor dar
abrazos y todo eso compartir con otras
personas animales también eso es
sumamente
poderoso y te da felicidad
y dejarlo ir
oye a morir a alguien y volvemos a ese
punto pues como que lo dejó ver con
crema felicidad porque si lo piensas dos
segundos te va a dar cuenta que si no lo
dejas ir va a ser muy triste por mucho
tiempo y tómate el tiempo que necesites
para procesarlo y mejorar pero déjalo ir
porque cuando lo dejas ir se va a
convertir en algo positivo algo que le
saca provecho y algo que pasa contigo y
te ayuda a seguir creciendo y mejorando
déjalo ir todos estos puntos son
para que para lograr la felicidad
personal
la vida es corta
corre rápido corre rápido cuando estás
creando cosas constantemente haciendo
cosas diferentes la vida es
rápida y se mueve cuando ponemos en
rutina en modo de repetición así se nos
pasa la vida y no hicimos grandes
la vida es corto
dense cuenta de eso
si se acuerda la pregunta inicial de que
harían
hubieran o alguien les dijera que
tuvieran un mes para vivir normalmente
las respuestas vienen rápido no pues
viajaría a roma éste comería todos los
tacos que quiero este le diría a mis
padres como realmente me siento saldría
del closet me metería al closet este
cualquier cosa miles de respuestas y los
obtenidos a través de las décadas que he
pensado en estas cosas ha obtenido
increíbles respuestas o ya pues que me
mata que me va a matar voy a buscar la
cura para esa cosa o me voy a donar la
ciencia o simplemente voy a tirar esto
no va a ser nada o me voy a ver tele
todas las series que quise ver voy a
jugar más con mis niños
miles de respuestas
ahora viene la pregunta realmente
interesante
qué harías si alguien te dijera
que te quedan 50 años para ti
y si entiendes
que la respuesta o las respuestas a
ambas preguntas son exactamente lo mismo
siento yo
qué has descubierto el secreto de la
miel
muchas gracias